Speaker 1: So earlier this week, just by virtue
of some clips we were looking at, I ended
up talking a little bit about areas where
the right just crushes the left on activism.
Now, I use the term activism loosely because
a lot of what the right is doing is not really
activism.
It's sort of demonization and it's really
sort of a different animal.
But to the extent that the right is able to
get organized in certain ways, they crush
the left.
And that includes at the local level, I've
talked about city councils.
I've talked about funding, the sort of training
of young conservatives as they come out of
college, which the left barely does.
I've talked about school boards and so on
and so forth.
We now have an article that perfectly illustrates
this point, and it should really scare the
left because the left is terrible at this
type of stuff and it's allowing the right
to just do it and to win on a lot of these
increasingly cultural issues, which is the
battle they've chosen to fight.
Understand that the right has abandoned fighting
on policy.
They're fighting cultural issues.
And this is a perfect example.
Take a look at this article in Truthout.
Right wingers are taking over library boards
to remove books on racism.
Now we hear this and we go, oh, my goodness,
this is so retrograde.
This is so backwards.
We could be this this energy that's been being
spent on this could be spent on a thousand
things that are more valuable.
And I'm with you.
But the point is they're not doing it and
we're not fighting them as as efficiently
and as intelligently as we could.
Listen to what the article says.
When Joe Mikula decided to run for the board
of the Nile's main public library in Niles,
Illinois, this spring, a community member
asked him how he thought the library could
better serve the area's increasingly diverse
community.
Many were stunned by his response.
Instead of stocking up on books in seven different
languages, he said, if we got people to assimilate
and learn English, that would do more good.
That's not policy.
That's a cultural issue at the time of his
candidacy.
McCullough was a known person in Niall's having
previously led efforts to impose term limits
on elected officials and stop the town mayor
from filling vacant trustee positions.
But his interest in the library was new.
Elizabeth Lynch, a member of the Save Niall's
Library Coalition, says she doesn't know what
provoked McCullough's involvement.
But it became apparent his goal was to object
to the library being a community center.
He also opposed to spending the spending to
repair the building's aging roof and upgrade
the facility to better bridge the digital
divide separating low income residents from
their more affluent neighbors.
But despite or perhaps because of his political
outlook, McCullough won the April election
and now holds a seat on the library board.
It goes on to say, Since their swearing in
on May 19th, the new board has wasted no time
in imposing its agenda.
Their focus is to change the very nature of
the library.
They've slashed the budget from seven point
four to five point nine million, fired staff
or reduced hours, gone from 70 hours a week
to 54 of being open, eliminated outreach to
schools and nursing homes and and end.
They are starting to actually weigh in on
what books should be allowed.
Some locales are making opposition to critical
race theory, their core focus, but other locations
are adding virulent opposition to comprehensive
sex education.
LGBTQ, Y.A., plus acceptance in a trio of
concerns.
They are fighting this from the ground up
now.
Is it disgusting?
Of course it is.
Is it retrograde?
Is it the stuff of let's go back to the fifties
and that that these right wingers dream of?
It's all of that and I'm against all of it.
But much like I think Mitch McConnell's actions
have been disgusting, can anyone say Mitch
McConnell hasn't been a hugely effective Republican
from the standpoint of pushing the right agenda
and blocking the Democratic agenda?
Absolutely.
And so unless we are going to get down and
fight them in these areas, we're just going
to keep losing on a lot of this stuff.
And we can go back to some of the clips I
played for you earlier this week.
Here's the clip of from CPAC.
This was an interview with a couple of people
at CPAC.
Remember, this is the stuff I pointed out
and I said they are smart to fight at this
level,
Speaker 2: pay attention to their children
and what they say when they come home from.
Don't criticize.
Listen, if there's things that go against
what they've been teaching their children,
then they need to go to a school board meeting.
Speaker 1: We all and they do and they do
is what we're learning.
Speaker 2: Need to read the books that our
kids are being forced to read so that we can
have an honest conversation with them.
There's a way to fight back.
And the way to
Speaker 1: do it is use your words and use
your money.
Go to your schools.
Don't send your kid to an indoctrination camp
and they're doing it.
OK, here's another one.
This was just a random interview.
I mean, as far as we know, sometimes these
are plants.
But as far as we know, this was a random interview
at CPAC.
And listen right away to what this woman,
I believe, from California says for sure.
Speaker 3: What do you.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I am California and I'm an
activist and I believe in what we're saying
here about getting involved in stuff.
But I think we forget to mention that how
we're going to do that.
We need to get back into the neighborhoods
to do in California right now, we are organizing
precincts and voter registration.
We're not talking about voter registration.
Speaker 3: I think that's actually that's
a great point.
I'm glad you came up to us
Speaker 1: once these people understand it.
Now, am I saying the left doesn't understand
it?
No, I think the left probably does understand
it.
I think the left probably does understand
it, but they're crushing us on this stuff.
And so I am restating the school boards, the
library boards.
I mean, listen, when you think of a library,
this is so micro, but politics is local.
Think of a library.
The very people that I'll I'll give you even
a specific example.
You walk around on a small town's main street
and you see people panhandling, asking for
money.
And the conservatives say this looks terrible
and this affects property values and many
on the left that say the same thing.
Great.
OK, well, let's get these folks jobs.
Many of them don't have Internet access.
Many of them you would need Internet access
in order to get a job.
So where can you go and get Internet access?
Well, you can go to libraries.
I have a friend who's a librarian who says
we have lots of folks that come in and they're
what they're doing on our computers with free
Internet access is applying to jobs.
So being able to do that would get folks off
of the street, which is what conservatives
claim to want.
And it wouldn't get them off because of welfare.
It would get them off because they got a job.
Great.
But then the conservatives go in and they
say, let's slash the library budgets and let's
make the computer room smaller or eliminate
them altogether or not replace the computers
or whatever the case may be.
So not only are they beating us on a lot of
this stuff by beating us on it, they continue
to perpetuate their talking point, which is
look at all this terrible stuff going on in
the panhandling and the Democratic mayor.
Well, it's not the Democratic mayor.
Maybe it's that conservative library board
that is making it so that a lot of these folks
don't have a place to go and apply for jobs.
It's a micro example, but it illustrates exactly
what we're up against.
And it's just, you know, that just dropped
right in after the conversation we had on
Monday.
So let's we've got to refocus on that and
we'll have more to say about it
in
the future.